People are annoying. Huh? Who the would read that?
Hey, cats is going to be creepy as. Huh?
How the are they going to make a movie cats? They might as well, like,
have you seen the musical cats? Oh my God, dude.
Hey, go yourself.
Do you know why it's in my trashcan?
What'd they call them gelical Oh,
you're going to make up a word in a musical about cats.
That sing, dude. Hey,
go yourself.
It's so bad, dude. And then finally they go to
mammaries and I'm like, all right, cool. And then they, the songs not even long.
And I'm like this, bro. Imagine an adult for real going like this
with claws. They gonna to make a movie about it.
Let me tell you right now.
Right now the movie cats is going to eat in the box office.
It's going to eat, dude. I'm telling you right now,
cats, movie.
I know movies that are going to tank and are not going to tank by the way I come
to me. Hollywood, watch the cats movie trailer.
That's a creepy lemme. I haven't seen the trailer yet. So let me look at it
and then I'll let, I'll let you know if it's actually gonna bomb or not.
It's human cats. You know,
they're just cartoons or they're real people though. Who said cartoons?
One chance. Of course, one chance always with one chance and the
Judy Dench, it looks like they're just wearing cats.
They just pretty much,
they look like two chains because they have necklaces on and. Oh,
this will make a lot of movie. Cause it's kids.
Bad. CGI.
It's weird as
gyms.
You just Elba Hudson.
Ian McKellen, Taylor Swift.
Oh Jesus rebel Wilson. Sammy Davis Jr.
Jesus Christ.
[inaudible] nobody's going to see a movie about a human
[inaudible] dude. That's so creepy.
Nah, nah.
I know what movies are going to bomb.
What is another movie that was of course going to bomb. Oh, what's that movie.
And I like these actors too. I don't know.
I don't want to make enemies more enemies. You know,
there's a movie out there that was going to bomb so bad.
You should have known and they should have known why are they making these.